promotion d'un traitement qui n'a pas
montré son efficacité diffusion de
fausses informations auprès du public
graves manquements au devoir de
confraternité réalisation d'essais
cliniques dont la réalité reste à
démontrer est la charge est lourde et
elle vient de la société de pathologie
infectieuse de langue française
une association qui regroupe les
personnels de santé intéressés ou
impliqués en pathologie infectieuse
celle ci forte de plus de 500 adhérents
accuse le professeur aoun d'avoir
enfreint pas moins de neuf articles du
code de déontologie médicale
sans surprise le traitement à base
d'hydroquinone rockin promu par didier
rahout figurent parmi les points qui lui
valent l'hostilité de ses confrères le
professeur didier raoult ndt a
délibérément prescrit de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine souvent associé à deux
l'azithromycine à des patients atteints
de kobe 19 sans qu'aucune données
acquises de la science ne soit
clairement établie à ce sujet est en
infraction avec les recommandations des
autorités de santé et les auteurs de la
plainte vont même plus loin il accuse
l'infectiologue marseillais de ne pas
avoir réalisé ces essais cliniques dans
le cadre légal requérant l'inclusion des
enfants ou encore l'autorisation d'un
comité d'éthique
les soutiens du professeur raoul n'ont
pas manqué de relever que le conseil
d'administration de la spilf affiche des
liens d'intérêts assez conséquents sur
le site de l'association rose fort knox
ainsi qui permet d'explorer la base de
données transparence santé on trouve
associé à l'acronyme spilf plus de 850
lits l'euro davantage convention et
rémunérations diverses offerts par de
grands laboratoires depuis cinq ans
parmi eux le géant américain gilead
figure en bonne place avec plus de cent
mille euros lui tout seul
quant aux membres du conseil
d'administration ils déclarent ensemble
toujours selon heroes for dogs plus de
1,6 million d'euros de liens d'intérêts
sur les cinq dernières années
suite à ces révélations nous avons
contacté la société de pathologie
infectieuse
mais notre demande
ces lettres mortes alors que didier
raoult et multiplient les critiques
contre les décisions du gouvernement
notamment sur l'obligation du port du
masque que risque-t-il vraiment si l'on
s'en tient à cet article du code de la
santé publique
pas grand chose du moins concernant ses
déclarations les enseignants chercheurs
les enseignants et les chercheurs
jouissent d'une pleine indépendance et
d'une entière liberté d'expression dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions
d'enseignement et de leurs activités de
recherche sous les réserves que leur
imposent conformément aux traditions
universitaires et aux dispositions du
présent code
les principes de tolérance et
d'objectivité didier rahout s'est il
montré tolérant et objectifs le conseil
de l'ordre des médecins en jugera
s'agissant des autres accusations si la
plante suit son cours normal elle
devrait d'abord donner lieu à une
proposition de conciliation entre les
deux parties
si celle-ci n'aboutit pas le dossier
sera instruit par la chambre
disciplinaire régionales la procédure
qui vise le directeur de l'i h il
devrait s'étaler sur un peu moins d'un
an et elle pourrait conduire dans le
pire des cas à une radiation définitive